Thousands of tons of radioactive water have entered the Pacific Ocean...
...from the crippled Fukushima nuclear plant in Japan.
No one knows how much radioactive air and steam escaped that plant...
...after the March 11th earthquake and tsunami.
So, what is radioactivity?
How does an element become radioactive?
And when does it become a danger to life?
Ralph Anderson, the chief health physicist...
...at the Nuclear Energy Institute in Washington DC,...
...says it all starts with the splitting of atoms or fission.
A split uranium atom releases more neutrons...
...which split more uranium atoms, creating a chain reaction.
This creates a lot of heat.
Rays of energy, like X-rays, are also given off. This energy is radiation.
We're exposed to radiation every day.
The Earth gives off radiation but nothing like the sun,...
...there's a whole spectrum of radiation from the sun including invisible ultraviolet radiation...
...that causes sunburn.
Scientists measure radiation in millirems.
We're exposed to about 300 millirems of radiation a year.
How much is bad for us? Scientists say anything over 10,000 millirems a year.
At the crippled Fukushima plant, there are certain radioactive elements...
...that are of most concern to scientists.
But contaminated water pouring from the plant into the Pacific ocean...
...is reportedly millions of times above levels considered safe.
What the long-term effects of the catastrophe at the Fukushima nuclear plant...
...in Northeastern Japan will be, only time will tell.
I'm Todd Grosshans.